all right mike marth mike mccarthy was
through some stuff in his first game as
head coach of the dallas cowboys he
addressed yesterday going back
watching the game copy
of that call
of pass interference on receiver michael
gallup that wiped out a long game that
would have potentially given the cowboys
a chance to win at a minimum given him a
chance to tie
here is cowboys coach mike mccarthy
addressing his reaction when he had a
chance to look at the
video of the call that was made
i mean the michael gave call i mean it
just
made me sick when i watched the tv copy
i thought michael ran an excellent route
you know he gets his hips
over top of the dbs and you know db
uh attempts to clamp his arm and
actually just clamped his arm and he
pulls his arm out and makes makes a
catch it's definitely a call
you like to see not happen and i know
everybody wants to talk about you know
the time of the game and you know in the
way the game was called to that point
but at the end of the day it was an
excellent route and throw
in completion by michael gallup and dak
now it was mccarthy who talked about the
time of the game after the game he said
basically i don't expect a flag to be
thrown in that situation it's where the
whistle gets swallowed and the flag gets
jammed down into the pocket his argument
yesterday was on the merits that it
shouldn't have been a call under any set
of circumstances
that it wasn't past interference and you
know i remember a time when coaches were
worried about getting fined for
criticizing officiating
if he doesn't get fined at a minimum
there's going to be a memo sent out this
week there's going to be a memo to go
along with the make sure you wear your
masks memo yeah be sure to drink your
oval teen and a
be sure not to criticize the officials
or else and uh i'm surprised right out
of the gates and i know the nfl's got a
lot of other stuff they're worrying
about but i have a feeling that's going
to register on someone's radar screen
and mccarthy's going to get a reminder
along with the rest of the coaches don't
criticize the officiating well i i i
would imagine so you're right um
again i think this is why i'm glad we
don't have past interference replay i i
thought it was past interference if you
don't call that we're never going to
like the dbs we're never going to stop
anybody
that just my look
that really is the defensive backs are
already at such a disadvantage yes there
was hand fighting going on
but when you have that final push as you
see there look he's got his arm locked
he's got to get his arm free what do you
mean his arm's not locked i can see the
opening
jalen ramsey's hands wide open
he's yeah because he's pushing away now
okay we had his he had his arms
look right there okay got his he's got
his arm grabbed
very subtly but very subtly you're right
and you know what why is mike why is
michael gallup got his arm on him
already why did he do it jalen ramsay
didn't create that contact gallagher put
his hand on jalen ramsey to start and
then extends so i have no problem with
that call my big question when i hear
those type of things from mike mccarthy
in the press conference is i want to
just go my next question would be coach
are you going to coach your receiver to
do the same thing next week in the game
that would be my answer and if he says
yes i would go well man we're going to
see this weekly basis because new
england teams that win like that bill
belichick is going to fix his team off a
play like that and go we can't do that
that's going to get called yeah i might
not think it's pass interference but
here's another smart coach that thinks
it is past interference so we got to
coach this off our team go ahead what do
you got to say this is the next level
that a bill belichick would take it bill
belichick knows which crew is more
likely
to call probably that too
probably here's the thing though the
crews have been reshuffled this year
yeah because of geographic proximity
they want minimum travel for the
officials but i think that's a factor as
well you know who's more likely to call
that you know who's less likely to call
that and it's just another factor that
gets put into this giant vat this giant
blender of circumstances and i don't
know how aware you can expect your
receivers to be in a given moment
or at a given game but that's part of
coaching hey today hey michael today
don't be afraid to give him a little
something you can get away with it today
next week maybe not today you can get
away with it and i think that's part of
of good coaching it's one of the reasons
why belichick has six super bowl
championships definitely i don't
disagree with you one bit there smart
coaches hey this hey this this referee
this referee crew hey dbs they're
they're a little they're a little loose
with you know how much you can hit a
receiver in that five yard box they'll
let you hit them seven eight yards
downfield so if you want to take one
more shot at the receiver when he goes
past iron go ahead do it this week
whatever that may be yes coaches usually
have a good feel for that but i think
generally the really good coaches will
try to coach that stuff out of their
players games all together just to be
like we're gonna play this is the rules
we're gonna play by the rules because
when i enforce them and i'm on them
every day in practice it translates to
the game and then we don't have
a 50 50 whether that's a penalty or not
type moment
in the biggest moment of the football
game and i think that's what really goat
coaches would do and i would imagine
that mike mccarthy at some point tells
him just hey yeah everything was great
maybe just watch the little the
extension of the arms because as we saw
even with like aj green at the end of
that chargers bangos game
that was a little more egregious but
it's the same type of thing once those
arms go like this and they're connected
to a db and the db shows any sign of
being affected by it the referees see
that and they might not even always see
it clearly they just see the extended
arms and they're going to throw it out
whatever the penalty
bill belichick is going to drill it into
his guys to avoid it because
that will kill you in little bits and
pieces it screws up field position it
kills drives it extends drives to the
opposing offense it's 5 10 15 yards spot
foul for pass interference on the
defense that can completely destroy your
chance of winning so it's a point well
taken but i do think that that
reasonable minds can differ on whether
or not that was past interference yes
and some officials are going to call it
and some exactly and the challenge is to
figure out which ones will and which
ones won't and in those games where they
won't you give them a little you give
them a little extra just just a little
pop just just a little pop just a little
something
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports